معنى من مدينه كهرمان مرعش مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد العظيم محمد عبد العظيم في
اليوم السابع ولا زالت فرق الانقاذ تعثر
على ناجين كيف يبدو المشهد مع مثل هذه
الاخبار
بالفعل ما تنتهي فرق الانقاذ من البحث في
منطقه وتنتقل الى منطقه اخرى ويبدا العد
التنازلي لفرص
الوصول الى ناجين وكان هناك شعور في مدينه
كهرمان مرش ان الامور قد فرص العثور على
ناجين قد انتهت وان معظم المناطق التي
زرناها اليوم هي عمليه رفع انقاذ انتهت
فرق الانقاذ من العمل فيها الا بعض
المناطق التي تعد على اصابع اليد الواحده
لكن فرق الانقاذ في كهرمان مرش عثرت وصلت
قبل اقل من ساعتين من الان الى شخصين طفل
عمره ثلاث سنوات بقي تحت الانقاض
159 ساعه وخرج حيا نقل الى مستشفى ميداني
شابه ايضا عمرها 37 سنه في نفس الوقت بعد
159 ساعه
اخرجت من الانقاض حيه ونقلت الى مستشفى
الميداني هذه الاخبار رفعت معنويات فرق
الانقاذ وذوي المفقودين الذين ينتظرون
اخبارا عن ذويهم من تحت الانقاض ولا زالوا
يرابطون في بعض الاماكن لا زالوا يرابطون
هناك اماكن تم اخراج جميع من كانه فيها
بين احياء واموات اما هناك اماكن لا زال
هناك غائبون تحت انقاضها وفرق الانقاذ
تعمل عليها قبل اللحظات وانا اقف هنا في
البث المباشر معكم جاء بعض الشباب بينهم
شابه تقول تبحث عن قناه محليه تركيه تقول
انهم والدها
ظهر في صوره وهو ينقل على سديه
في هذه في القناه في احد الاماكن التي
كانت تبث منها نريد ان نصل هذه القناه حتى
اعيد واشاهد الصور اتاكد هل فعلا هو هذا
والدي اريد ان اسال اين المكان الذي اخذ
اليه وهكذا هكذا هو الوضع الحال في مدينه
كهرمان مرعش الكل يتعلق
بامل العثور على ذويه من تحت الانقاذ لكن
للاسف الكم الكبير من مناطق
المدمره هي اصبحت خاليه من فرق الانقاذ
ومعظمها تم نقل هذا اليوم
بقايا الدمار وبقايا البيوت المدمره تم
نقلها بسيارات الشاحنات التي تاتي وتذهب
حتى في الصوره الخلفي هذا المكان يتم نقل
منه
البقايا الى خارج مدينه كهرمان مرعش وهذه
هو المشهد العام الان في مدينه كهرمان
مرعش ولا زالت هناك فريق انقاذ تركي وصيني
في المنطقه القريبه من هنا اشاهدها خلف
الكاميرا لازال هناك فريق انقاذ لديه امل
بالوصول الى شخصين تحت الانقاض استشعر
هذا هذين الفريقين استشعر
اثار لحياه لديهم تحت الانقاذ ويريدون
الوصول اليهما لكن للاسف احدهما تحت تسعه
امتار تحت الانقاض والاخر تحت ثلاث امتار
تحت الانقاذ
والامكانيات والظرف صعب
الكتل الكارتيه تكبست فوق بعضها ولنا ان
نتخيل حجم الصعوبه التي يعانيها فرق
الانقاذ في الوصول الى الذين هم تحت
الانقاض والعمل مستمر
ولا زلنا نسمع بين الفينه والاخرى بين
الساعه والاخرى العثور على ناجين تحت
الانقاذ رغم ان كل الخبراء تحدثوا وقطعوا
الامل الايام الماضيه عن فرص العثور ناجي
وكل يوم يقولون هو هذا اليوم الاخير ولا
توجد فرصه بعد هذا اليوم لكن اراده الحياه
اقوى من اراده الموت
وفرص الفرص لا زالت قائمه في العثور على
ناجين ونحن على وشك نهايه اليوم السابع
لهذا الزلزال المدمر شكرا لك مدير مكتبنا
عبد العظيم محمد من كهرمان مراش